you know who else had a big premiere
last night a lot coming hard invitation
you didn't know Kevin Hart right you
were doing well we all know the Kevin is
very competitive so I just had to ask my
stars board is holding their premiere
tonight what would you say to Bradley
Cooper and Lady gaga why are they on
your night I would say thank you for
doing a movie about me the star is born
[Music]
the most magical most fun night ever and
I can't wait to see you guys later on
Tiffany Haddish plays Kevin's teacher in
night school the pair posed in front of
a row of orange lockers for last night's
premiere the 38 year old actress dazzled
in a floor-length Tadashi Shoji gown you
came sexy tonight did yes the Unicorn is
done it's like meanwhile keV rocker red
double-breasted suit and I thought he
was finally giving me wardrobe props oh
wait a minute
keV do you like my jacket no what's
wrong with this the same thing that's
awfully strong can't dress for gymnastic
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]